James and Karlee caught a
lizard in their backyard.
Its body is 17/8 inches
long, and its tail
is 10/8 inches long.
What is the length of the
lizard's body and tail
together?
So good thing we have
the lizard obediently
standing next to our
measuring stick or our ruler
or whatever this happens to be.
And we have it
marked off in inches.
And not only that,
we have it marked off
in eighths of inches.
Notice-- this is an inch, and
we have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8 sections of that actual inch.
So, let's see, 17/8 inches long.
This is going to be 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13,
14, 15, 16, 17.
This right over
here is 17/8, which
you might notice is
also equal to 2 and 1/8.
8 goes into 17 two times
with a remainder of 1.
But we won't talk
about that just yet.
But we see that's the length
of the lizard's body-- 17/8.
I just counted off 17 of these
8's right over here-- 17/8.
And then they say that the
tail is 10/8 inches long.
So it's another 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So this distance right over
here, I just counted off 10/8.
So that's another
10/8 inches long,
and it gets us all the way to
the end of the lizard's tail.
And they say what is the length
of the lizard's body and tail
together?
Well, that's going to be
the length of the body
plus the length of the tail.
So you have 17/8 plus 10/8.
Well, that's going to
get you to 17 plus 10/8,
which is equal to 27-- 27/8.
And so this mark right
over here is 27/8.
And if you wanted to write
this as a mixed number,
you could just say, well,
8 goes into 27 three times,
and you have a remainder of 3.
So this is equal to 3 and 3/8.
And you see that on the
ruler right over here.
It's equal to 1, 2, 3.
And then we have
another 1, 2, 3/8.
These two things are equivalent.